>> We're about to have Margery Krevsky, the
author of Sirens of
Chrome, the enduring allure of [INAUDIBLE].
Margery co-founded Productions Plus located
in Bingham Farms, Michigan,
in 1981 and the agency has quickly grown -- grew
to one of the major
players in selecting and training talent for
auto shows.
Productions Plus has recently evolved to become
a full-fledged talent
management firm and has offices in LA and
Chicago.
Margery and Productions Plus, the talent shop
are also involved in
booking talent for conventions, toy shows,
food demonstrations and
movies being filmed in Michigan, which is
exciting.
So without further ado, please help me in
welcoming our guest, Margery
Krevsky.
MARGERY KREVSKY: Thank you, thank you.
And it's wonderful to be here and hello to
everyone out there in
simulcast land, too.
Today, I'm going to take you through Sirens
of Chrome.
You have the book in your hand and Sirens
of Chrome -- that's the name
that I give to people, the models, that work
the auto shows.
It's not just the cars that are wonderful,
although if you read a quote
from me in the newspaper, it will be at the
auto show, the cars are the
stars.
But we have to remember that cars cannot talk.
They are fabulous, magnificent, mute, beautiful
creations but they can
not talk so someone has to talk for them.
So from the beginning of auto show history,
someone has had to do it.
So I'm going to take you on that ride.
And it is a very interesting ride of history,
but I'm going to tie it
into fashion too, just because I'm a girl
and I like fashion, so we're
going to do that.
And we are going to compare some of the automotive
fashion to the
regular fashions that people wore in those
days too.
So it's kind of a multi-layered talk, Sirens
of Chrome.
I'm very proud that Sirens of Chrome did win
in Michigan one of the
2009 most notable books, and it sure doesn't
hurt that Michigan is
known as the car state.
And this is the first section of my talk talked
Awakening the Wheels,
and our timeframe is 1900 to 1920.
People ask me when did the first auto show
begin?
Well, there's a big fight between Chicago
and New York about where it
really started.
And from the research I've done, I think that
at the Chicago coliseum
and the first Sirens of Chrome or product
specialists were not gorgeous
models, were not gorgeous men or women -- you
have to remember the year
was 1905 and people didn't even know if cars
really worked.
Most people had transportation they had a
horse and buggy, and they
weren't sure that a car, a mechanism, a machine
could really be
reliable enough.
So the people you see in this picture up here
are a family, and the
gentleman is a physician because he did house
calls.
They did those in those days.
And if the physician chose a car over a horse
and buggy, that was a
pretty strong statement.
So the first product specialist or Sirens
of Chrome usually were
families because cars were marketed to families.
Now we are in Michigan and, of course, Detroit
is known as Motor City
and the very first show in Detroit was at
the Detroit fairgrounds in
1908 and this is a very rare photograph of
that.
Notice the name signs on here.
Daimler, which was one time was a very significant
name in car
manufacturing.
And also over here, it says McKay in Auto-motion.
At the time Henry Ford started to create his
concept of a car in an
assembly line, he had an engineering background
and there were hundreds
of other engineers, especially in Michigan
and on the East Coast who
thought I can make cars too.
And they could.
They were many different cars made.
The only difference was they were engineers,
they could create a car,
but you had to know how to create lots of
cars and then market them.
Now we're going into the Awakening of the
Wheels, 1900 to 1920, and
this is when Detroit really became nicknamed
the Motor City.
You go back in time to the 1920s, and I have
the fashion photographs up
here and they are in the book.
Fashions changed radically.
They were pretty hip for their days.
Women's skirts came up, hair got cut, makeup
became acceptable, and
people began to look at cars not only as basic
transportation but also
it began to have a fun element with it also.
And here is a very interesting poster of the
advertising of one of the
first Detroit auto shows.
So America gets Detroit as the Motor City.
The next 1920 to 1940 I call the Combustible
Years, because these were
years when engineering and the creation of
motors and things that made
motors work better became created.
And at the middle, I have a picture of the
human hood ornament.
And remember this, we're going to see this
motif carry out in every
decade.
In fact if you go to the Detroit auto show
which opens on January 16,
you may even see a reproduction of many of
this.
In the combustible years, what happens to
cars?
You had two slides of previous cars where
they were kind of boxy, they
were always in black, but now we get curved
bumpers, sleek, shiny
hoods, and the beginning of the human hood
ornament theme.
The combustible years, 1920 to 1940, Ford
productions soars.
Of course, being from Michigan, the name Ford
is a very, very strong
element in the consciousness not only of the
state but also the United
States.
But the Ford production soared to -- and you
will see in the corner --
25 million automobiles meaning that that reached
across the nation.
Also in 1930, a very significant piece of
art was done at the Detroit
Institute of Art by Diego Rivera.
Ford commissioned him to do the murals in
the center lobby.
And if you haven't seen them, it's really
a statement of how the Ford
industry and the automotive industry becomes
engrained in American
culture.
Now one of the things I'm going to do along
with just talk is I'm going
to also show you some fashions.
And I'm going to begin with a fashion and
Renee if you are come out
here.
This is Renee.
Renee is not just a model Renee is a Sirens
of Chrome.
Renee it a model but she has been a product
specialist for the auto
show floor all around the country for five
years working for Nissan.
And she is wearing vintage auto show clothes.
These are clothes that stood beside these
magnificent, mute vehicles
and talked about them.
The dress organza, the year 1950, and she's
carrying with her the car
to which the dress made coordinates.
The color of the dress is pretty much the
same color as a 1950 Ford.
Now go back in color history a little bit,
this was very radical, very
avant-garde and very, very forward for 1950.
But, of course, the dress is very lovely.
It's still in fashion now.
If I could fit in it, I would wear it at some
point also.
Thank you, Renee.
And she'll be back with three other outfits.
But we're going to go to the combustible years
between 1920 and 1940
and this picture from 1938 is one of the first
documented pictures of
women, Sirens of Chrome, who are literally
talking about an engine.
They're performing a skit demonstrating the
workings of the Chevrolet
engine.
And if you could, in the -- if you could just
jump into that picture,
you would see the energy that this created
at the auto shows.
They had people in very glamorous gowns, and
notice the picture book
has and the gloves talking about the inside
of the engine.
Started in this era and continues.
If you'll notice the GM picture, 1936, people
packed to the auto shows.
The auto show began to be part of the Americana
culture people wanted
to go there.
It was definitely part of America.
And it wasn't just for guys who like cars.
It was for the entire family.
Because people began to realize, even in the
1920s to the 1940s that
women were very interested especially in the
interiors of the cars and
the colors.
In the combustible years, 1920 to 1940, show
business really got into
the act.
The picture that you see here from 1939, there's
no business like car
business.
There was a phenomena is America there called
the Ziegfield Follies.
This phenomena became interpreted into the
auto shows and many of the
preview nights that opened the auto shows
began with extravaganzas that
were very similar to the Ziegfield Follies.
However, instead of having the star name come
out, they would have
chorus girls and they would have musicians
and magicians and songs but
it was the star that came out that was human,
the star was the car
surrounded by all of this.
And here is a 1927 hood ornament, actually
she is one of the Marion
Morgan dancers of the year who was hired by
Packard to go around the
country doing interpretive dance around the
cars.
The Apex of Excess, 1940 to 1960.
And I call this the Apex of Excess for this
era and there was also
another era of excess and that was in the
1980s.
Here is our hood ornament, again, a Jean Seberg,
the actress, like
look.
Very sleek.
Very dramatic.
And what was excessive about automobiles at
this time?
Excessive chrome.
You'll notice in the very upper right of the
Buick, the very massive,
very strong grill on the front, the curves,
the fins, and the bumpers
and right at the middle top, I found this
wonderful photograph of
fashion at the time which was also excess,
and that is the jacket with
a modified hip line having almost wings.
This was at the beginning of the 1930s and
saw that that really related
to what was happening in automobiles at the
time too.
The warriors came, 1940 to 1944, something
very interesting happened in
our country.
We had all of these great assembly lines that
were making major cars
for manufacturers.
But during the war, from 1942 to 1944, they
all stopped.
Literally, car manufacturing stopped during
that time so that these
companies could produce tanks and munitions
for the war.
But some of the advertising and the marketing
still remained because
there were still a lot of cars out there and
used cars that could be
sold.
So this picture called Holding Down the Fort
from 1942 is one of those
rare photographs.
If you look very carefully in this photograph,
it's in the book that
you have, there is a license plate on the
front and it has the initials
of 41.
That is the first recorded instance of a vanity
plate.
So Ford really started the vanity plate.
In 1943, when some of the soldiers started
to come back from the war,
ads began to run such as the one you see on
the right announcing that
you're coming back in with the saying you're
on the beam, which is I
think a naval expression, I was told, in 1943.
So we come back -- hello?
[PAUSE]
We come back --
Our next era is 1940 to 1960.
And in 1960 and this was my age, I love
the 60s.
And I have Renee over here.
Renee do you want to come in?
This is my absolute favorite that you're going
to see today.
Psychedelic power, 1960s.
I love the dress, but you have to know what
car this stood beside, the
1960s, of course the group was the Beatles.
And Rolls Royce created for John Lennon, the
Rolls Royce Phantom, the
psychedelic phantom.
And this car actually was --
Thank you.
[PAUSE]
This car actually was at Greenfield Village,
I think was about a year
ago, and I remember going to see it, and taking
this dress to just
stand beside it.
And it is a beautiful combination of the Siren
of Chrome in the perfect
dress with the perfect car that really is
a historical car.
And used a great deal, I understand, by John
Lennon who really loved
it.
Thank you.
Now what else happened in the 1940s to the
1960s?
Imports began.
That may be a bad word in Detroit, but it
did happen.
And if you look at the bottom, BMW began with
their small little car
the i7. This summer I sat in an i7 at the
Sloan Museum when they had
one of their car shows.
It's very small, it's very cramped.
I'm 5'9", but it sure is a cute little car.
And they were able to get all of these lovely
sirens to come in the
car.
Also what's happening in the Apex of Excess
is in the middle you see a,
an ad that appeared in Life magazine called
Fashion on Parade.
And what was happening in automotive design
was they decided, you know,
we have all these designers, and they're these
designers who are just
looking at cars, but if we were to look at
what was happening in
women's fashion.
So automotive designers and this started with
General Motors asked a
designer at the time, Hattie Carnegie, to
design a dress or an ensemble
for each one of their brands.
And that is in the book.
And it is a great panorama of fashion and
car design for that era.
And I love the look of the concept sports
cars.
Sport cars have pretty much always been with
us, but especially in the
1950s, they started to become very, very glamorous.
And notice the very glamorous Siren of Chrome
that they have beside
that sports car.
Now Apex of Excess.
This one picture on the left, the Chicago
Auto Show, Cadillac debutante
concept car from 1950.
One of the reasons that I wrote this book
is whenever I go out to
dinner, I have lots of car stories to tell.
Some of them I think are true.
Some of theme I know are true.
And some are probably fantasy.
This car picture I thought was fantasy.
I then heard that Cadillac in the 1950s developed
a concept car and on
the inside, the interior was lined with Somali
leopard pelts.
Now I did not think that was true.
But it was a great story to tell.
The research for this book was mainly done
at the NAHC, the National
Automotive Historical Collection at the Skillman
Library in Detroit,
and I mentioned this story to one of the librarians,
and she said, you
know, I think that might be true.
I think I've seen that picture.
So, you know how you're supposed to be very
quiet at a library?
She brought the picture and she put it down
in front of me.
And I had to just scream because it really,
really was true.
Because people had been telling me that -- it
is so politically
incorrect to do now, that in the 50s they
couldn't even conceive it --
but they did.
And notice the Siren of Chrome, or the model,
who is in the car, she
has a dress with complimentary color in custom
Somali leopard.
And I think it took -- I have it listed in
the book -- over a hundred
skins to, to create that.
The other thing that is amusing in this time
in the 1950s Sirens of
Chrome were not all on the auto show floor.
Television was a very, very big thing.
And Dinah Shore who is the singer you see
in that sports car, in the
Chevrolet sports car, was on TV every week
and she ended her show with
a little song See the USA in your Chevrolet
and that became a thought
that just went through your head all week.
And she appeared for Chevrolet and General
Motors at many auto shows
around the country.
And thus began stars, movie stars, songstresses,
singers who
represented cars.
And here are other famous people who are Sirens
of Chrome.
There is Cary Grant at the BMW i7.
Gorgeous Cary Grant.
There there's a wonderful story behind this.
This was taken -- this was taken in France
just after he and Grace
Kelly had completed their Alfred Hitchcock
movie and he very much want
today stay in Europe.
And so the contract with BMW permitted him
a very luxurious summer
there.
And then Greta Garbo.
Greta Garbo was very famous for her beautiful
legs and so when Mercedes
brought out the new bench-type of seating
at the Detroit Auto Show,
they brought in Greta Garbo to display this
beautiful leather seating.
And there she is luxuriously draped on the
seat with her beautiful mink
coat.
And then at the top, Miss Americas.
Literally from the beginning of the 50s until
very, very recently
[INAUDIBLE] company usually General Motors,
and they travelled all over
the United States and went to dealerships.
[INAUDIBLE] from 1956 she's standing [INAUDIBLE]
Detroit, and behind
them are all of the sirens of the automotive
business.
And then below it are the starlets.
All the Sirens of Chrome maybe you don't know
their names, but they
worked very hard to bring glamour and information
to the, to the auto
show.
Apex of Excess, 1940 to 1960, we continue
with very unusual cars like
James Bond car.
You know, all those early James Bond movies,
they always had those
great cars, those were one of the biggest
draws to the auto show
especially in the 1960s it certainly didn't
hurt that some of the
starlets would come along with the stars.
You see Jaguar beginning to make a very big
presence at auto shows.
And Ford motor company with this great photograph
on the right one of
their concept cars, this is called a uni-wheel
car.
One wheel that would balance the entire car.
Very unusual concept, but what else is unusual
about the photograph
fashion-wise was think of the 1960s.
Women wearing pants at the beginning of the
1960s was very, very
fashion forward.
So when you look at these photos now, and
you have to think about where
did they -- where did they come from.
1960s, the car becomes the chick magnet.
The automobile is so engrained in the [INAUDIBLE]
of Americana and the
styling is so sensational and sexy that it
does become a chick magnet.
And now Renee, let's take our next wardrobe.
We're going to ahead about 20 years, this
is 1980.
And do you remember me talking about the Apex
of Excess?
In the 1980s, you can't over-design anything
anymore.
You had ruffles, ruches, sequins, pearls.
But this is what was happening on the auto
show floor in the 1980s.
And this was also the time a Farrah Fawcett,
hair and big hairdos.
And the car that she has is the very special
version of the Corvette
and of course, the Corvette is one of the
signals of great looking,
sexy cars.
I'll just quote you the name of the color
of that pink, it's called
Bitchin' Pink.
And I didn't name it.
That came from the creative team that did
that.
And this was another outfit that was on the
floor of the auto show.
Thank you, Renee.
Then, we continue from chick magnet to muscle
car mania in the 1970s.
And the dress that you saw that she wore from
the 1960s could also go
into this.
You will notice cars began to have car detailing.
And they have a lot of work that's done in
the front, cut out in the
front, grills are different they're not just
massive, they may be
indented.
So the muscle car mania began.
And in fact on Woodward Avenue in Detroit
every August, the Dream
Cruise brings out the best of these muscle
cars.
Something happened during the 1970s and 1980s
in the muscle car
segment.
And that is the racing circuit began.
We always had racing ever since cars could
go on a track we have had
racing.
But it really started to take hold during
the 70s and 80s.
Every automotive company decided they would
have either their own
racing team or they would support a, a vehicle.
So we begin to see also a lot of advertising
on cars during the racing
circuit also.
And here is [INAUDIBLE] excitement and I put
in this slide because this
slide is General Motors, Pontiac Fiero.
The name play is going away but it certainly
was an exciting time at
the auto shows.
Because the color of Fiero red was bright,
sexy, and very identifiable.
And also this was the beginning of creating
T-shirts and memorabilia in
the special colors of those cars.
And now we come to the present what happens
at auto shows.
We now have divas that become Sirens of Chrome,
and here is Celine Dion
doing a -- for the celebrity black tie evening,
singing for Chrysler.
And then at present shows, we have Sirens
of Chrome that are just very
beautiful around an Mitsubishi SST.
And auto shows are not only part of America,
[INAUDIBLE] but they are all over the world.
And I've taken most of these pictures except
the one in Shanghai.
There's a show every two years in Paris, show
in Frankfurt, I took
pictures from there.
And it is really global.
Almost every major city in the world hosts
some kind of auto show.
And here we go into the future.
The power of the auto show which we will see
here in Detroit in the
next couple weeks, this is a picture of the
press conference.
And I love this Toyota i-unit, because not
only do you see cars but you
see concepts of other vehicles that the designers
are working on.
And then I love this picture from -- from
the 1950s, this is the Monte
Carlo, the Pontiac Monte Carlo.
And at that time, the big siren of the screen
was Gina Lollobrigida.
So they decided to do three very attractive
look-a-likes for that.
So that gives you a little overview of Sirens
of Chrome.
And do you have any questions about cars?
The era? The fashions or
the people that participated in it?
Sure?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MARGERY KREVSKY: That's correct.
So the question is beside being models and
probably looking attractive
do you have to know about the car?
You have to be a gear head.
And that's very deceiving sometimes.
Because when you go on the auto show floor,
you'll see people and they
look like models, and you'll think oh, that's
a very attractive man or
women -- and I say man or woman because there
are both men and women
that are product specialists -- but all of
them go through a very
rigorous training program.
I know just within my company we handle some
of those training programs
and most of them are at least five days.
You learn about the culture of the automotive
company.
You learn about each model.
You learn about some of the future things
that they're doing, and you
learn about, usually the top 10 or 20 questions
that people might ask
about the vehicle.
Although you can never know everything, that
you have a source to go
to.
But you can talk car.
You know about the business.
You know how an engine works.
You know what a carburetor is.
You know what a [INAUDIBLE].
You know what a fuel injection engine is,
and also you can explain
today hybrid technology because a lot of people
are interested in green
and green vehicles, and what that means.
So before we take another question, I want
to show you our final dress
which is from the 1980s.
And I always use this one for last because
this is the Bob
Mackie-designed dress.
And I showed you the Pontiac Fiero.
This goes with the Pontiac Fiero and is called
the Flame Dress and was
one of four dresses he designed for Pontiac.
Actually some day this dress will probably
be in a museum because in
1982, it was on the auto show floor, and I
believe it was also repeated
again in 1983.
During that time Bob Mackie designed for movie
stars such as Cher and
other very, very glamorous stars, and here
he took a turn at designing
for the auto show.
And other designers that designed for the
auto show were Bill Blass,
Jeffery Dean, Halstead, all of the big names.
So that is our flame dress.
Thank you, Renee.
So that was a good question.
So they had to be attractive, but they also
have to be gear heads.
Because people are coming to the auto show,
sure they want to see the
car, but a lot of people really want to know
what the technology is and
what's under the hood and how is this one
different from the other
competitor.
Competitive information is a very important
part of the training.
And also part of the training is driving the
cars.
You can't talk a car unless you really driven
it and can talk about
it's take off.
You can say the car goes from 0 to 60 in like
ten seconds, but until
you experience that, you really can't talk
about it intelligently.
So thank you for that question.
Any others?
[PAUSE]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MARGERY KREVSKY: Well I think that everyplace
that has an auto show
has a Siren of Chrome.
My area of expertise are the national auto
shows.
But certainly every hot rod show, every small
little parking lot that
says in the summer, we'll have at auto show
here, so bring your car
out.
Cars and autos are just part of our DNA.
When I've travelled around the country to
my book signings, some of
the -- one of the first questions I'll ask
someone is what was your
first car?
And just like you can never forget your first
kiss, you never forget
your first car.
What was your first car?
>> Dodge Caravan.
MARGERY KREVSKY: See? See?
And my was a VW beetle in turquoise, and I
even named the car.
We have such affection for cars in our -- in
our lives.
But yes.
Every single motor show probably has a Siren
of Chrome standing beside
it.
And the reason is the same all over, and that
is the cars are hot,
they're great, they're historical or just
loved by someone, but they
can't talk.
And so someone needs to talk about them because
we are interested in
them.
Any other questions?
Yes, Lindsey?
>> How many models do you staff for the Detroit
auto show, for
example?
MARGERY KREVSKY: About 200.
Around 200.
And someone in my office will correct me when
I get back and say, no,
it was 250.
But that is a massive project but -- I want
you to remember the first
auto show of the year does not start in Detroit.
The first auto show really is in September
and usually starts with the
Texas state fair which has the longest running
auto show of any city.
That auto show which is part of their fair,
runs 30 days.
Most auto shows run anywhere from 7 to 10-day
in major cities like
Detroit, New York, Philadelphia, Boston, Miami,
Los Angeles, and
Chicago.
And then most, what I would call, moderate,
medium cities have auto
shows also.
Buffalo, Providence, San Antonio, Texas, also
have auto shows.
So it's all over.
There are 73 auto shows all over the United
States from September until
May.
Then those shows stop and then summer events
begin with automotive.
>> What's your favorite auto show?
MARGERY KREVSKY: My personal favorite, besides
the Detroit Auto Show
which is where -- where I live, is I like
the Chicago Auto Show because
it's in the dead of winter there, and you
would think everyone would
want to stay just holed up in winter, but
it is amazing to me the
families of the people that bring brave major
snowstorms to come to see
the auto show and the first day at the McCormick
Place at the auto show
people are lined up.
But you say "favorite."
They're are many favorite elements that I
have of other shows around
the country, too.
For example, the San Diego Auto Show in California
you can't beat the
location.
The San Francisco Auto Show which is usually
over Thanksgiving time,
brings the holiday atmosphere to it because
it's usually open on
Thanksgiving day.
People are filled with holiday spirit.
The New York Auto Show opens usually Good
Friday or the Saturday after
Good Friday, and so it's Easter and people
come through that show on
Easter day all dressed up.
So it's a very wide, wide span, and I enjoy
them all.
Or you go down in Miami and people come through
there from South Beach
and that's a show in itself.
Yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MARGERY KREVSKY: Well as far as innovation,
you can't keep the human
spirit of creativity down.
So it can't be a relatively depressed economic
time, but that created
creative spirit is still there.
However what can be realistically interpreted
and what people will buy
is another thing that needs to be decided.
But the ideas that I hear coming out of automotive
companies that
design, the design studios are pretty amazing.
I was at the LA Auto Show last month, and
Honda had a press conference
and one of their main focuses during that
press conference was new
design.
They had their designers speak.
Their executive spoke, but mainly they focused
on some pretty
interesting new things that potentially could
come out.
And most people now are very interested in
the hybrid cars, [INAUDIBLE]
I always like today think from 1900, the beginning
of my book, until
2008, that was phase one of the great automotive
industry.
I do believe we are seeing now in 2009, 2,010
that next, that next
venture, and I think it will be pretty exciting.
When you see historically in pictures where
we went in a hundred years,
just imagine where we're going to go now just
with the technology.
And my car right now, sure it drives great.
But the technology in it is really great.
I can talk on the phone, it will tell me where
to go, it will tell me
if I'm -- if I'm going to hit something.
It's really cool.
[PAUSE]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MARGERY KREVSKY: Fashion-wise how are they
displaying technology?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MARGERY KREVSKY: You'll have to go the auto
show and see.
You'll have to go -- because I can say the
words, but you have to see
it and then have somebody stand beside you
and take you through it.
It would be like displaying a computer for
the first time.
You're going to get the same -- it looks like
a box, you're going to
open the top, you're going to turn it on and
whatever.
And you will just have a wonderful time because
it's right there.
It's like a fun time.
And how does that relate to fashion?
When you go to the auto shows, half the exhibits
exhibit houses really
in my opinion are art houses.
And they need to showcase these cars to make
them look great, but also
I stand there and I look and I think, that
display could be the Museum
of Modern Art.
And not only do you see American designers
but also when you go to the
BMW or you go to one of the other manufacturers
in Europe you see what
those design heads think is very cutting edge
also.
That is wonderful it is like going to a museum
in some ways so come.
I'll meet you there.
>> Do car companies or the [INAUDIBLE] go
out and look for designers
that they have a certain designer that they
think is really hot or
[INAUDIBLE]?
MARGERY KREVSKY: Well, in our company, we
have a very special woman
and her name is Sherry Garnett, and she happens
to be seated over
there, Sherry stand up here.
And Sherry Garnett is a graduate of Parson's
School of Design.
You've seen Project Runway and Tim Gunn and
Heidi Klum, well, she's our
Heidi Klum and Tim Gunn combined at Productions
Plus.
And she has a pulse, ever since I think she
was little, because the
design was in her mind and she was going to
be a designer.
She does a lot of research and has the pulse
and an understanding of
each brand that we represent and that's a
very critical thing.
And in her mind, she will create conceptions
and she will draw them out
and present them to the automotive decision
makers and from that
discussion, and it is a major group of meetings,
the wardrobe will
result.
The things that you saw on Renee as part of
the mini-fashion show did
not just happen.
These were deep, deep thoughts, the color
had to be perfect, the design
had to be perfect.
I can only imagine all of the behind-the-scenes
discussion on that
flame dress that you saw because the flames
had to look right.
They had to be part of the same advertising
thought and [INAUDIBLE]
that was already there.
So great questions.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MARGERY KREVSKY: Well, and also that goes
with fashion.
If you look what's happened in fashion, fashion
is a lot more classic
now.
An example of that would be the Lexus, the
Lexus people.
Informed Sherry Garnett that they wanted to
do things that were very
classy and classic and they wanted a named
designer on their floor.
And so they chose a designer and that designer's
thought happened to be
very classic clothes.
And at first look, you would look and say,
that's a navy suit, that
looks pretty classic but when the look at
the cut, and the structure,
that could really stand up for years.
So they were going to more elegance instead
of more flash.
And as you saw with the 80s and that little
pink number that was over
designed, that was a lot of flash.
So car design and fashion design changes,
change as well.
But I think we go to the auto show this year
and there's always a
mixture.
You're going to find a very sleek styling
but there's always something
that really out there and wild too.
>> Can you talk a little bit about your role
or your company's role in
the Michigan film industry?
MARGERY KREVSKY: Sure and that's another question,
and the question is
talking about my company's role in the Michigan
film industry.
And that's a -- that's a great question.
Because as most of you know, in Michigan during
the past year and a
half, the State has given some very hefty
tax benefits to anyone who is
coming to the state of Michigan to make a
film.
As a result, a industry started here about
a year and a half ago.
And so there are many major producers and
directors that are coming in
to cast most of these films.
You've probably seen the film, Clint Eastwood's
film Grand Torino, of
that cast done here.
The major stars still come from Hollywood
but most of the other actors
come from here, and we do a lot of that actor-finding.
We work with casting agents.
In fact yesterday, we had a casting session
-- and I don't know I'm
allowed to say the name of the movie, but
the director from Los Angeles
came in, looking for children, looking for
second leads and looking for
character actors.
And there are 130 [INAUDIBLE] now that are
slotted to be filmed here in
Michigan that have been approved for funding.
And as the largest film and talent provider
in the state, we hope to
have a lot of that.
So auto show is show biz and show biz is show
biz.
But it's a good question.
Anything else?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MARGERY KREVSKY: I wish I had a crystal ball
so I could answer that.
But I do have some thoughts on that.
And number one yes, Cobo Hall is an issue,
you read about that all the
time.
But the city found several million dollars
to fix it up for the show or
I think everyone would have been very, very
unhappy.
So there have been some fix-up things.
And as far as the show with the economy and
the car business, we have
graphs in business and on the graphs, things
go up and things go down.
It's basic math when you see a graph, and
so we're going through a very
unusual and challenging period now, where
on the graph we are going
down and we hope that it keeps going up.
So also, it's an interesting time in business
because the people who
were in business who weren't as committed,
may not be here anymore but
those who are really in it to win it and really
be part of this
business are a part of it.
So it is a very interesting time.
Okay.
Lindsey, thank you.
Thank all of you and thank you for your wonderful
questions and you
like, I would be happy to sign any of your
books afterwards.
Thank you.